we know of course that the Russians are
launching a multi-pronged attack in all
parts of the country
any defensive military person will tell
you that you've got to outgun them
somewhere but there's nowhere that the
ukrainians can outgun the Russians the
numbers are just too great
if we have a look a bit a bit more
closely at the donbass region let's look
at the donbass
the Russians may not be making as much
progress here as they had actually
thought originally we know that forces
have left the Crimea Peninsula going
westwards northwards and possibly
eastwoods towards the area of the
Donetsk itself and the original idea
almost certainly was for the Russians to
move out from the West to join up and
form this land Corridor that we know
that they're very interested in doing it
may be that the ukrainians are able to
hold them there and that link up
according to latest information doesn't
seem necessarily to have been made let's
look at Kiev Kiev itself of course is
the main issue
again the Russians may not be making
quite as much progress in Kiev as they
had hoped the uh
the uh attack line from Belarus seems to
have reached the outskirts of Kiev the
attack line from the Russian Frontier
may not yet have reached Kiev so it's
possible that the Russians haven't got
around here all the forces that they
originally expected to have
if we just have a look at a satellite
image of Kiev
itself I mean Kiev is a city of three
million people
uh the uh Nipa river runs all the way
through the middle of it
um it has got of course all the
embassies in it uh it's an important
place it's got its airfields and its
airports the fact is at some point in
the next 24 hours the Russians even if
they're slow in getting there from the
Russian border will be in a position to
surround the capital
um to penetrate as we know they've
started to do from the north and they
will dictate their own terms and what
those terms will be we will probably
find out in the next 24 hours